et tout de suite place à notre second
débat que se passe-t-il avec les aides
fe vous savez ces zones à faible
émission depuis l'instauration de ces
zones interdites aux véhicules les plus
polluants dans les grands dans les
grandes villes en gros rien ne va plus
comme avant chez les élus comme chez les
habitants chez les salariés chez les
entrepreneurs chez les commerçants la
révolte gronde au point que le Grand
Paris par exemple Lyon repousse les
échéances pour apaiser les tensions
reportage regardez à Marseille où la zfp
est vécu comme une injustice par les
automobilistes qui préférait que tous
les gros pollueurs de la ville soient
mis à contribution c'est un sujet
d'Adrien pas
depuis le début de l'année interdiction
pour certains véhicules polluants de
rouler dans le centre ville de Marseille
cette zone affaiblission ou ZFE concerne
plus de 300 000 marseillais pourtant sur
le littoral qui longe son périmètre se
situe la deuxième zone la plus émettrice
de CO2 en France le Grand port maritime
de Marseille poumon économique de la
ville et le trafic maritime n'y fait pas
l'objet de restriction y compris lors
des alertes pollution les écologistes
demandent la mise en place d'une ZFE
aussi pour les bateaux il faut lutter
contre ça en même temps qu'on fait la
ZFE automobile sinon en fait on résout
pas le problème dans la réalité on
s'attaque aux gens que des voitures
souvent dans des quartiers les plus
pauvres où c'est compliqué de changer
les voitures et où les aides au
remplacement de voitures suffiront pas
les associations et des habitants ont
porté plainte en mars contre X pour mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui au sujet de
la pollution maritime un paquebot a même
été bloqué l'été dernier par des
militants à son entrée à Marseille parmi
les critiques un navire de croisière
Raquet émet autant pendant une heure que
30 000 véhicules roulant à 30 km
alors depuis 2019 le Grand port maritime
de Marseille permet une connexion
électrique à quai pour trois séries en
même temps un moyen de couper leur
consommation de carburant le port promet
que ce sera possible d'ici 2025 pour des
bateaux de croisière Philippe tabarrau
rapporteur d'une mission d'information
du Sénat sur les ZFE a pu faire le point
sur place on vient sur le sujet des ZF
plutôt automobile mais également quelque
part indirectement maritimes parce que
le port doit être inclus dans cet effort
de décarbonation le grand port de
Marseille n'attend pas les obligations
de l'état où les obligations européennes
mais d'ores et déjà rentré dans une
phase active le maire de Marseille a
lancé une pétition l'année dernière
Benoît Paillon exige des actes forts
pour réduire la pollution des navires du
côté de la métropole la mise en place
d'une ZF maritimes n'est pas envisagée
pour le moment d'après sa présidente le
mistral ramènerait la pollution même si
les bateaux les plus polluants étaient
éloignés
de sens n'a pas de sens parce que le
jour de vent c'est la ville qui prend
directement toute la pollution donc il
vaut mieux aller au cœur du problème
c'est à dire électrifier les quais la
région a investi beaucoup d'argent le
département métropole aussi on a mis 6
millions d'euros nous attendons les 10
millions qui nous avaient été promis par
le maire de Marseille pour justement
continuer l'électrification en octobre
2022 le gouvernement a annoncé le
lancement d'un groupe de travail visant
à créer des et des feux maritimes
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir Philippe la barreau bonsoir vous
êtes sénateur LR des Alpes-Maritimes on
vient de vous voir à l'écran on vous
voit autour de la table vous êtes membre
de la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire qui vient de mener une
consultation publique sur les zones à
faible émission et vous nous en parlerez
à vos côtés Daphné chamards bonsoir vous
êtes responsable des questions de
mobilité inclusive et durable au Secours
Catholique on va accueillir il est en
retard
Erwan beneze journaliste au service
économie du Parisien et puis bien sûr
Mathilde Siro qui m'accompagne tout au
long de cette émission et donc jusqu'à
la fin alors avant d'aborder les
problèmes et les éventuels solutions on
va essayer quand même d'être très
pédagogique pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien de quoi on parle je vous
dis ça parce que une récente enquête de
l'institut CSA menée en avril montrez
que un Français sur deux n’était pas
vraiment capable de définir ou ne savait
pas ce que c'était qu'une ZFE c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être une partie
d'ailleurs du problème
peut-être on peut commencer on se
demandant comment cette idée a vu le
jour quels étaient les objectifs
avec vous
oui alors la zone affable émission
l'enjeu il s'est avant tout un enjeu de
santé publique aujourd'hui quand on
parle des zones affaiblissement il faut
bien comprendre que c'est un dispositif
qui vise à interdire progressivement la
circulation des véhicules les plus
polluants santé publique pardon pour
améliorer la qualité de l'air pour la
santé citadins exactement puisque les
polluants atmosphériques donc on parle
des particules fines des NOx dont on a
déjà eu l'occasion de parler à sur
différents enjeux du designate etc ça
c'est un enjeu majeur en terme de santé
publique pourquoi parce que la pollution
de l'air c'est la troisième cause de
mortalité évitable en France avec selon
les études entre 40 000 et 48 000 décès
par an et on sait que ce sont
particulièrement les véhicules les plus
anciens qui émettent et particulièrement
une diesel qui émettent le plus de ces
polluants atmosphériques donc l'enjeu il
est de sortir progressivement et ça
cette notion de progressivité elle est
fondamentale ces véhicules pour
permettre en fait d'avoir un air plus
respirable notamment d'un des
territoires très dense on sait que la
pollution y est très forte on est dans
une phase d'expérimentation au début des
années 2010 je crois que Paris démarre
en 2015 faut peut-être rappeler que la
France a été condamnée par la Cour de
justice européenne en 2019 après 10 ans
de mise en demeure quand même pour
manquement aux obligations de la
directive qualité de l'air et puis se
dispositif ZFE il va être étendu et
rendu obligatoire d'une certaine façon
dans la loi climat et résilience en 2021
oui même avant sur la loi d'orientation
des mobilités donc comme vous l'avez dit
condamnation de l'Europe condamnation en
France par le Conseil d'État qui a
condamné l'État en 2021 et en 2022 et ce
ne sont pas que des condamnations
symboliques parce que c'était sonnant et
trébuchant c'était 10 millions d'euros
d'astreinte par trois fois donc ce sont
de véritables condamnations donc le
gouvernement et le législateur ont réagi
à travers la loi d'orientation des
mobilités qui a décidé que 11 métropoles
dans notre pays qui étaient en
dépassement aller donc mettre en place
des ETF
immédiatement et ensuite une deuxième
loi vous l'avez justement dit climat est
résilience elle est accélérer un petit
peu le calendrier des 11 premières et
aller également prévoir que environ 32 à
33 agglomérations de plus de 150 000
habitants supplémentaires rentreraient
dans ce dispositif avec un calendrier un
petit peu plus resserré et ce qui
porterait le total de ce de ces
agglomérations à 43 à peu près c'est ça
et tout commence à partir de 2025 je me
retourne vers vous Daphné chez Martin
pour expliquer au téléspectateurs
comment ça marche concrètement comment
c'est quoi une ZFE alors une ZF c'est
une zone avec un périmètre défini où on
va dire et bien progressivement à une
certaine période de la semaine où tout
le temps et bien un certain nombre de
véhicules avec des vignettes critères
qui pourront plus circuler la vignette
critère c'est un une petite vignette
c'est un dispositif qui se base sur la
motorisation du du véhicule donc essence
des ailes électriques et l'année de mise
en circulation de première mise en
circulation
elle devrait aujourd'hui il faut en
faire la demande c'est une demande qui
est faite sur un site prime de critères
pour un gouv.fr comme à peu près tous
les sites aujourd'hui donc c'est une
demande c'est une démarche qu'il faut
faire ça c'est déjà un angle ce n'est
pas obligatoire ce n'est pas
systématique quand vous achetez un
véhicule neuf vous n'avez pas forcément
la vignette ni quand vous faites le
contrôle technique donc c'est déjà un
premier pas c'est à dire que quand on
est dans un territoire qui est concerné
dans une zone affaiblissement déjà la
première étape c'est de faire la demande
de vignette critères parce que pour
rentrer je suis désolé d'être très
concret mais pour rentrer dans cette
zone il faut la vignette sans pare-brise
si vous en avez ici vous n'avez pas de
vignettes vous ne rentrez pas à
condition de contrôle est bien sûr mais
voilà exactement le principe c'est de
dire et bien si vous avez une vignette
critère 3 de 1 donc on part de il y a
les vignettes non classées donc ça c'est
pour les très vieux véhicules et puis
c'est progressif 5 4 3 2 1 donc tout à
l'heure quand je parlais de
progressivité c'est par rapport à ces
vignes là c'est à dire que
progressivement on va avoir des
agglomérations qui vont dire en 2026 les
véhicules dotés d'une vignette critères
5 et 4 ne peuvent plus rentrer dans ce
périmètre défini puis deux ans plus tard
on va dire c'est plutôt le ce sera
maintenant en plus les vignettes
critères 3 et progressivement pour
arriver en fait finalement à des zones
où on aura très peu de véhicules diesel
et un maximum de véhicules qui émettent
moins de particules fines et de NOx
alors c'est très clair merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps Philippe Tabaro à
quel niveau faut-il gérer tout ça est-ce
que c'est la commune est-ce que c'est
une agglo du coup qui décide et puis
entre les communes est-ce que chacun
fait ce qui lui plaît il y a pas est-ce
qu'il y a un schéma fixe qui est qui est
donné par l'État ou est-ce que chacun
dessine sa zone comme il l'entend et
choisit les jours où on peut y aller ou
pas y aller alors il y a quelques règles
qui ont été définis comme ça a été dit
dans la loi d'orientation des mobilités
dans le climat résilience après la main
était donnée au territoire et le
territoire le plus pertinent est celui
de la métropole ou de la communauté
d'agglomération donc à l'intérieur de
cette métropole les élus choisissent le
périmètre qui peut être à certains
nombre de communes de dans la métropole
ou simplement une partie de la métropole
on a rencontré les 11 présidents des 11
métropoles concernées et chacun éditer
des règles très différentes on
correspond à quoi globalement on imagine
les vieux centre-ville historiques mais
peut-être je me trompe c'est la base
mais dans d'autres territoires on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a des communes en
plus de la commune centre qui sont
concernés et des communes un petit peu
en périphérie ça pose d'ailleurs un vrai
problème et c'est la base aussi des
discussions aujourd'hui des tensions qui
existent ça c'est pour le périmètre mais
ensuite il y a les règles donc il y a
les règles alors je me suis aperçu en
échangeant avec les 11 présidents des
métropoles que fruits de concertation
fruits d'échange avec leurs administrés
avec les commerçants avec les artisans
qui viennent tous les jours travailler
dans ces zones affaiblissement il a été
décidé par exemple que la zone
affaiblissement fonctionnait cinq jours
sur 7 pour certains
la journée et pas le soir pour d'autres
pour favoriser la vie nocturne les
spectacles les restaurants et pour ne
pas les fermer une certaine partie de la
population donc on voit que les règles
sont totalement disparaître comme
d'autres ont choisi de les mettre en
place 7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24
avec quand même un système de dérogation
qui peuvent être 12 dérogations dans
l'année 24 dérogations dans l'année bref
il y a des règles qui sont totalement
différentes d'une métropole à une autre
et donc pour vous il y a pas un meilleur
système qu'un autre c'est vraiment du
coup humain en fonction du territoire
moi je trouve que c'est pertinent qu'on
ait laissé la main au territoire et
qu'ils puissent s'organiser en fonction
de leur connaissance par contre à terme
se pose déjà et se posera de manière
plus accrue un problème d'harmonisation
et je pense notamment quand il y a des
ZFE qui sont très proches les unes des
autres on a l'occasion d'auditionner des
des artisans qui nous ont dit notamment
en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes on a un souci on
doit travailler dans une même journée
sur Lyon sur Saint-Étienne sur Grenoble
sur Valence pareil dans les hautes
françaises également dans les ZFE qui
doivent se mettre en place donc problème
d'harmonisation tout en laissant la main
au territoire Mathilde est-ce qu'on a
des exemples à l'étranger de zones à
faible émission
est-ce que le fonctionnement est à une
des particularités et est-ce qu'on sait
qu'elle est l'efficacité de cette
dispositif si on a déjà des bilans
peut-être que Daphné peut préciser nous
dans le rapport on aura une partie qu'on
remettra donc d'ici là la mi-juin avec
mes collègues de la Commission du droit
comparé c'est vrai qu'on entend souvent
cet argument de dire les ZF fonctionnent
bien à l'étranger pourquoi elles ne
fonctionnerait pas aussi bien en la
première question qu'on peut peut-être
poser c'est est-ce que ça marche du
point de vue de la santé publique pour
prolonger la question de Mathilde en
gros est-ce que l'air y est meilleur et
ce qu'il y a moins de malades on
rappelle que c'est 48000 morts c'est ça
en France l'estimation du nombre de
morts liés à la pollution exactement
mais santé est publique France estime à
000 morts ce qui est sans vouloir être
déprimant ça c'est le côté mortalité
mais en fait c'est ça engendre aussi des
maladies très importantes on voit aussi
par exemple à Paris le développement de
l'asthme du nourrisson ce type de
maladie ça fait aussi partie des effets
de la pollution alors là où ça a été mis
en place que ce soit en France peut-être
ou à l'étranger est-ce que ça fait
baisser la pollution alors aujourd'hui
les principes de ZFE ça existe et ça va
exister dans 320 villes européennes donc
c'est pas un produit franco-français les
retours qu'on a c'est notamment par
exemple à Londres où on a observé
effectivement une diminution en termes
de polluants atmosphérique qui qui est
positif on a une diminution aussi du
trafic routier et la diminution du parc
automobile et donc en fait grâce à la
zone qui a été mis en place il y a
vraiment cette cet effet de diminution
du trafic et donc des particules
ou moins de décès alors aujourd'hui
c'est assez difficile puisque comme
c'est une cause de mortalité évitable on
n'a pas sur les certificats de décès
décédé de la pollution donc on sait
qu'il y a des effets positifs mais vous
savez c'est voilà c'est une cause de
comorbidité finalement aujourd'hui dans
le monde il y a une seule personne dont
sur l'acte de décès il a été précisé
qu'elle était décédée de la pollution de
l'air parce que en fait c'est multiples
ça vient renforcer des phénomènes donc
on n'a pas une étude générale pour qui
vient à tester des effets sur la
mortalité mais par contre les
estimations sont plutôt positives
d'accord donc ce sont des estimations en
tout cas pour certains élus ça reste
difficile à mettre en pratique écouter
par exemple ce qu'on dit la sénatrice
LRD Hauts-de-Seine donc votre collègue
Christine Lavarde
aujourd'hui nous avons une ZFE et
effectivement comme il n'y a pas de
contrôle ou en tout cas pas de contrôle
automatisé dans les faits elle est quasi
inopérante puisqu'il faudrait avoir un
contrôleur à chaque endroit où on rentre
dans la ZFE les jours de pollution donc
autant dire qu'on ne les a pas donc
effectivement et l'État c'est engagé à
mettre en place des contrôles
automatisés au dernier trimestre 2024
donc ce qui coïncide au calendrier
d'après les Jeux Olympiques Philippe
tabarrau il y a un problème de contrôle
évidemment c'est ce qui est revenu
partout alors là les 11 sont d'accord il
n'y a pas de contrôle il n'y a pas de
contrôle et puis les territoires ne
souhaitent pas faire les contrôles pour
la plupart d'entre eux ils disent c'est
une responsabilité de l'État donc l'état
s'il souhaite nous mettre cette lecture
automatisée des plaques pour autant nous
ça c'est des mini caméras installées des
feux rouges sur des panneaux à l'entrée
de la ZF parce que les Français n'aiment
pas trop en général
et puis et puis deuxièmement
comment allez-vous expliquer demain
par exemple à un certain nombre de
territoires qui connaissent des
problèmes de délinquance évidemment tous
les effectifs de police sont très
fortement mobilisés qu'il faut enlever
ces effectifs de police dans les
quartiers dit sensible pour les mettre à
contrôler les vignettes critères à
l'entrée ça peut être les mêmes agents
plutôt de la sécurité qui qui font les
contraventions quand on est mal garé non
c'est pas cela qui vu le nombre c'est
compliqué les polices municipales qui
peuvent servir à ça moi je choisis
Christian Estrosi mais j'ai déjà lu ces
déclarations il nous dit je ne veux pas
mettre d'agent de police municipale pour
contrôler une mesure qui a été décidée
par l'État d'accord donc pas contrôler
on imagine que c'est pas forcément du
coup très respecté bien sûr c'est la
base on en parlera peut-être plus en
détail tout à l'heure mais il y a une
question de clarté il faut l'information
et si on n'a pas l'information dans la
mesure ne peut pas être comprise et
deuxièmement il faut un contrôle s'il
n'y a pas de contrôle la mesure va
mourir de sa belle-mère Daphné chez
Martin qu'est-ce qu'on a raison de nous
cibler que les voitures d'une certaine
façon certains experts disent mes
couilles du chauffage du chauffage au
bois qui fait aussi beaucoup de
pollution dans l'air oui bien sûr après
ce qui est important de regarder c'est
finalement comme je disais tout à
l'heure les sources de pollution alors
bien sûr la voiture elle est dans un
panel de polluants de de facteurs de
pollution et en fait on sait que
majoritairement sur le dioxyde d'azote
c'est bien la voiture qui a le plus
grand impact bien sûr comme dans toute
politique et sur les enjeux écologiques
même si là on est sur quelque chose de
très sanitaire il faut pas se contenter
de cibler que qu'une seule source de
pollution et donc travailler aussi sur
la question du chauffage il y a eu la
bien sûr la question de du maritime
aussi ça semble essentiel parce qu'il y
a aussi un enjeu d'équité finalement
avec ceux qui ont la CAP capacité de
changer de mode de transport ceux qui
n'ont pas et donc voilà il faut aussi
prendre en compte les autres sources de
pollution pour qu'on arrive à réduire
les seuils sur les différentes sur les
différents polluants
ou zone à forte exclusion selon de quel
côté on se place
dans la consultation pour un certain
nombre de réponses et bien justement on
va en parler avec Tam tranny est-ce que
les Français acceptent ces nouvelles
contraintes on va faire le point sur
cette consultation avec vous Tam oui
c'est une consultation qui a eu lieu
entre mi-mai mi-avril à la recueillie
plus de 50000 réponses c'est un record
pour le Sénat et elle a permis de sonder
pour l'essentiel des Français qui savent
ce qu'est une ZFE déjà donc c'est pas
tous les Français et la plupart sont des
Français qui habitent majoritairement à
proximité les résultats ils sont très
clairs 1 86% des particuliers 79% des
professionnels sont O au déploiement des
feux énorme les ont principaux obstacles
les véhicules propres sont trop chers
l'accessibilité de la métropole est
insuffisante pour les zones avoisinantes
la mise en oeuvre du ZFE est jugé trop
rapide ou encore il juge qu'il y a un
manque de pertinence dans le classement
critère bref pour eux il est
urgent d'attendre pour les participants
à cette consultation qui je le précise
bien n'est pas un sondage donc ça ne
reflète pas la vie de tous les Français
me servent peut-être bien la vie de ceux
qui se sont mobilisés pour répondre au
sénateurs
qui sont pas tous très chauds pour pour
ces ZF c'est un sujet d'inquiétude
depuis déjà quelques temps déjà depuis
bien longtemps effectivement les élus
locaux à porter d’engueulades vont être
les premiers à traquer pour la mise en
place de ces zones qu'ils n'ont pas
décidé c'est là grande crainte des
sénateurs qui en plus d'être les
représentants des collectivités sont
élus par et je rappelle que nous sommes
en pleine campagne pour les sénatoriales
qui ont lieu au mois de septembre
prochain voilà ça n'aide pas la preuve
de l'intérêt du Sénat en tout cas pour
cette thématique c'est que 37 questions
ont été posées sur les ZFE depuis un an
au gouvernement alors pas seulement la
question orale question écrite et
question au gouvernement ça fait quand
même beaucoup et elle voit donc du coup
les problèmes soulevés par les AFE sous
toutes les coutures ça va de la fracture
sociale bien sûr aux demandes de
dérogation pour raison médicale par
exemple ça va du transport de
marchandises pour qu'il bah ça coûte
trop cher de s'adapter au sujet du
manque de contrôle dont vous avez parlé
à l'instant dernière question au
gouvernement pour le coup en date fin de
l'année dernière écoutez Clément bonne
qui fait l'inventaire de toutes les
mesures d'accompagnement du gouvernement
aux adefe nous avons déployé
progressivement en lien avec les
métropoles les aides pour que la mise en
place progressive des aient des feux se
fasse le mieux possible les ailes c'est
notamment l'acquisition le véhicule le
bonus écologique la prime à la
conversion il faudra pas temps avant que
les aides et feux deviennent des zones à
forte exclusion
je pense aussi que il y a dans cette
écologie culpabilisante il y a une
obsession de la comme plutôt qu'un souci
du bien public et puis aussi un mépris
social c'est quand même la France des
clopes et du diesel qu'on regarde encore
de haut et il y a dans tout ça un germe
de gilet jaune je vous remercie voilà
les adefes sont-elles les nouveaux 80
km/h la nouvelle taxe carbone qui peut
ressusciter le mouvement des gilets
jaunes telles et la question que pose de
nombreux sénateurs Philippe
Erwan Benezet
tout à l'heure journaliste au Parisien
on est on est ravi de l'accueillir c'est
le miracle de Public Sénat les gens
apparaissent sur le plateau comme ça
Philippe Tamaro juste qu'est-ce qui vous
a frappé dans cette consultation la
participation premièrement ça a été très
justement dit la précédente
participation sur cette question des 80
km/h avait été dans une 33000 réponses
là on est à pratiquement 52000 et les
autres sont très loin donc s'aperçoit
quand même que c'est quand on parle de
voiture et quand ça revient sur la
question des voitures que les personnes
se mobilisent le plus et pour les
résultats je dirais on n'est pas trop
surpris par rapport à ce qu'on peut
entendre les uns et les autres si ce
n'est que c'est massif quand même alors
le rejet massif notamment sur les
personnes qui sont tout à fait
défavorables ça monte jusqu'à 69
c'est-à-dire très défavorable et puis il
y a la sinon une interprétation une
corrélation qui paraît évidente quand on
habite à l'extérieur de la zone
affaiblissement quand on est ouvrier ou
retraités on est très largement
défavorable aux ZFE on est un petit peu
plus favorable aux ZFE quand on habite
au sein de la ZFE quand on est cadre ou
étudiant et qu'on a des transports en
commun qui fonctionnent plutôt bien
alors Daphné chez Martin est-ce que ces
ZFE sont génératrices d'inégalités
sociales
alors on ne l'espère pas en tout cas
nous on pense que il y a un enjeu il y a
un une urgence à agir sur cette question
là donc de ne rien faire c'est pas une
solution pour nous il faut peut-être
rappeler que les voitures les plus
pollantes elles sont généralement les
plus vieilles et sont généralement dans
les ménages les plus modestes ou les
plus défavorisés exactement ce qui est
quand même aussi à préciser on le voit
en tout cas nous au Secours catholique
dans les personnes qu'on accompagne et
on a vraiment un coeur de partir de ce
que ces personnes vivent c'est que
aujourd'hui il faut bien se dire que la
voiture elle crée aussi déjà des
fractures sociales parce qu'en fait
avoir une voiture ça c'est un luxe et ça
le sera de plus en plus dans ce contexte
inflationniste et donc en effet on a une
population modeste qui détient plutôt
des véhicules plus anciens c'est 38% des
populations les plus modestes qui ont un
véhicule critère 4 et 5 donc les plus
polluants contre 10% pour les plus
riches par contre on sait aussi que les
plus pauvres ont moins de véhicules et
que ça pose aujourd'hui des vrais
problèmes parce que dans un certain
nombre de territoires et vous l'avez
bien souligné notamment les territoires
des zones affaiblissement quand on n'a
pas de voiture et bien on n'accepte pas
l'emploi on n'accepte pas au service on
a la question de la santé qui
primordiale aussi autour des aidefe
parce qu'en fait nous on a beaucoup de
questions qui de se dire comment demain
moi qui habite dans le Puy-de-Dôme par
exemple je vais faire pour me rendre un
rendez-vous médical chez un spécialiste
parce que je devrais aller au CHU de
Clermont-Ferrand mais j'ai pas la bonne
vignette mais j'ai pas la bonne vignette
et je suis et je n'ai pas de solution de
record modal parce que j'habite en
dehors de de l'agglomération et donc il
y a peu de transports en commun et j'ai
pas les moyens financiers d'acheter un
véhicule et je suis parfois des horaires
où les transports en public ne
fonctionnent pas je pense aux salariés
qui font aussi des boulots la nuit
exactement donc effectivement si en fait
on a une politique une ZFE qui est
simplement on décide du jour au
lendemain de dire allez les véhicules
critères 4 et 5 puis 3 ne circule plus
sans un côté adosser un vrai plan de
transition et d'accompagnement des
ménages alors oui ça va générer des
inégalités sociales mais aujourd'hui on
a une un outil qui est cette politique
ZFE qui peut nous permettre de
travailler sur la question de
l'accessibilité rappelons que la
mobilité c'est un droit il y a le droit
à la mobilité qui a été défini dans la
loi d'orientation des mobilités donc la
mobilité pour tous c'est l'occasion de
travailler sur la santé et puis bien sûr
c'est l'occasion de travailler sur les
enjeux écologiques les enjeux
climatiques puisque les transports c'est
les premières facteurs développés des
transports alternatifs aux voitures
individuelles dans des territoires
parfois acculés ou des mobilités
alternatives c'est ça ne se fera pas du
jour au lendemain d'ici 2023 il doit
falloir on y est ou d'ici 2025 le
problème c'est un problème de
synchronisation par rapport aux
calendrier et ça a été très bien dit
dans l'enquête aussi ce que reproche les
personnes qui ont participé c'est de
dire que les choses vont trop vite il y
a un décalage entre les calendriers qui
sont donnés et avec la situation
actuelle dans certains quartiers j'étais
sur Marseille comme vous l'avez vu il y
a 48 heures le troisième arrondissement
de Marseille par rapport est un des
arrondissements les plus pauvres de
France voire d'Europe il y a
la loi est respectée sur les zones
affaiblissement d'ici 2025 52% des
habitants de ces quartiers qui doivent
changer leur véhicule comment vous
pouvez penser ça peut être possible un
instant donc c'est revoir le calendrier
et le synchroniser avec une politique de
transport en commun qui tend à se
développer à Marseille comme ailleurs
avec des aides qui tendent à s'organiser
pour faciliter les choses avec des
guichets uniques pour que les
administrés puissent s'y retrouver c'est
également une mutation de notre
industrie automobile c'est pas rien
aujourd'hui mais elle est encore en
retard sur ces questions notamment
électriques de lavitaillement du
financement du coup voilà toutes les
questions pour synchroniser et tout ça
va coûter cher on sait qu'il y a des
aides à la conversion est-ce qu'elles
sont bien ciblées Erwan et en gros
est-ce que ça va favoriser la voiture
électrique quoi est-ce qu'elles sont
bien ciblées oui elles sont ciblées mais
trop trop chichement d'une part elles
sont on dit parfois elles sont trop
généreuses pour quelqu'un qu'il faudrait
s'acheter un gros SUV électrique il veut
toucher le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui il y a très très peu
d'offres pour des voitures électriques
qui sont qui sont peu chères en dessous
de 25000 euros cette relativement
compliqué
et c'est l'inadéquation effectivement
entre donc l'offre des voitures
électriques qui on avait parlé de
l'effet ciseaux c'est-à-dire le le
moment où le coup à l'achat d'une
voiture électrique croiserait celui
d'une voiture thermique et on le on le
on le prévoyait pour 2025 aujourd'hui on
avait plus du tout là on sait même pas
si d'ici 2030 on le voit d'ailleurs avec
la difficulté avec laquelle le
gouvernement a du mal à mettre en place
son offre à 100 euros c'est là
aujourd'hui une équation économique
impossible alors pour l'instant ils
avaient de borne a renvoyé ça à
l'automne de de cette année on sait même
pas si on y arrivera sur la pauvreté des
populations on avait établi dans Le
Parisien il y a deux mois au mois de
mars de cette année une double
cartographie à la fois la cartographie
des et des feux et la cartographie des
les populations effectivement on voyait
que c'était là où évidemment sans
surprise on avait d'ailleurs interrogé
le cartographe Jérôme Fourquet le
sociologue sans surprise c'était là où
il y avait les populations les plus
pauvres que on trouvait aussi évidemment
les véhicules les plus anciens la
voiture la ville où les véhicules sont
les plus vieux c'est Valenciennes
qui a été le centre-ville a été le
fleuron à l'industrie textile
aujourd'hui population très pauvres les
populations se trouvent pas en zone
périurbaine les populations les plus
pauvres se trouvent dans le centre-ville
et c'est demain où elles vont être
exclues et je termine juste les une
sorte de quadruple Pen aujourd'hui pour
ces populations là c'est d'une part ils
ont pas accès à la voiture électrique
deuxièmement elles n'auront plus accès
au centre-ville troisièmement elles vont
continuer à être touchées souvent le
plus par la pollution et il y a même un
quatrièmement c'est toute cette
transformation il y a un risque de cas
social notamment sur la voiture
électrique quand il fallait 5 personnes
pour construire une voiture thermique il
en faut trois on sait pas comment tout
ça va s'organiser et donc c'est quand
même 10% de la population qui travaille
aujourd'hui qui qui travaillent de près
ou de loin pour l'industrie automobile
et là aussi il va y avoir un risque
encore une fois quadruple Pen et même
sans travailler pour l'industrie
automobile ça peut parfois poser des
vrais problèmes écouter par exemple ce
témoignage d'un chef d'entreprise
un site de production avec des équipes
en 3,8 et des horaires décalés donc la
voiture est le seul moyen de transport
possible pour tous les salariés qui sont
en équipe et ce qui est préoccupant
c'est que au 1er janvier 2024 on a
quasiment les deux tiers de nos
effectifs en production en équipe qui si
il ne se passe rien ne seront plus en
mesure de venir travailler la piste
de demander aux salariés de gérer la
situation elle nous paraît assez assez
difficile à mettre en oeuvre parce que
tout simplement même avec un bonus une
voiture électrique c'est un an et demi
de salaire pour pour nos salariés c'est
c'est pas envisageable pour la majorité
d'entre eux donc nous ce qu'on demande
c'est de la concertation voilà on est on
est une entreprise une fois de plus
citoyenne et responsable donc on prendra
nos responsabilités mais il est clair
que tout seul on y arrivera pas
bon alors comment on fait maintenant
comment on fait d'abord maintenant pour
soulager ou pour aider les collectivités
concernées Philippe Tabarro on lâche du
l'est on donne du temps on revoit les
règles alors je suis pas censé vous
donner les conclusions du rapport que je
donnerai à la mi juin mais quand même
quelques pistes je viens d'un évoquer
une c'est la question de la
synchronisation la synchronisation je le
rappelle entre le calendrier et la mise
en oeuvre des mesures d'accompagnement à
la fois pour changer le cas échéance son
véhicule mais pour obtenir et là vous
l'avez justement dit du report modal
l'objectif c'est pas de se retrouver
avec 40 millions de d'automobiles
électriques demain c'est d'inciter les
personnes à changer leur mode de vie et
puis d'organiser en fonction notre nos
plans de mobilité il y a des annonces
très intéressantes de la de la première
ministre sur le ferroviaire il y a des
expérimentations intéressantes de Cara
au niveau de service tout ça c'est très
bien mais ça prend du temps le transport
prend du temps donc il faut vraiment
synchroniser il faut informer on l'a dit
tout à l'heure et puis je pense qu'il
faut peut-être individualiser un petit
peu plus les choses que simplement des
décisions qui tombent comme ça il y a
des personnes qui entretiennent très
bien leur véhicule qui ne polluent
peut-être pas forcément et qui vont être
obligés de le mettre demain au rebut
comment on fait
comment on fait pour les pour ne pas
justement laisser laisser les plus
défavorisés en dehors de ça c'est ce
qu'on comprend bien que la voiture
individuelle qui changea de nature
jusqu'il deviendrait électrique ça reste
un problème donc c'est vraiment le
transport public ou c'est des mobilités
partagées des nouveaux modes de
déplacement en tout cas on a la
conviction qu'il faut conduire les mêmes
idées la même la même erreur que ce
qu'on a fait il y a quelques années en
se dirigeant vers un système tout
automobile où on a aussi fortement
incité les Français à acheter du
véhicule diesel et où aujourd'hui on est
dans un sentiment de culpabilité c'est
ce que ressentent nous les personnes
qu'on accueille et qu'on écoute sur le
sujet en disant mais on nous a demandé
d'acheter des véhicules et diesel et
puis en fait maintenant ça va plus donc
je ne pense pas qu'il y a une réponse
unique en disant comment on fait on
développe non en fait aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment se dire comment sur un
territoire on développe une palette de
solutions et pour prendre en compte les
différents usages de la mobilité parce
que selon la situation dans laquelle on
se place dans la vie dans son parcours
de vie dans ces moments que ce soit la
semaine ou le week-end c'est pas
forcément le même mode de transport
qu'il faut utiliser donc ça c'est
quelque chose de nouveau c'est un peu la
révolution des mobilités mais il faut
plus raisonner avec un seul mode de
transport en tout cas au-delà des modes
de transport ce qu'il faut déjà faire
c'est concerter informé dialoguer parce
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il y a
une méconnaissance on l'a vu autour des
zones affaiblissement les personnes ne
savent pas ce que c'est vous parlez de
vignette critères on parle de quelque
chose qui complètement les personnes ne
connaissent pas ne savent pas donc déjà
ce premier prérequis qui est de se dire
est-ce que mon véhicule a le droit de
circuler déjà on ne le sait pas donc la
première chose à faire c'est
l'information et écouter les personnes
en précarité pourquoi particulièrement
parce que ce sont des personnes qui ont
des horaires atypiques qui ont des
spécificités et donc en prenant en
compte des conditions voilà de d'habitat
des conditions de vie qui sont
spécifiques ça nous permet de penser une
offre qui est plus adaptée qui est plus
systémique il faut
que les politiques changent un peu de
lunettes ou oui certains clichés écoutez
par exemple Scandi Olivier Marleix des
adefe
un sujet qui m'exaspère au plus haut
point par exemple c'est les ZF les
oeuides à faible émission le fait que on
est plus droit de rentrer quand on est
comme moi à bouger d'Eure-et-Loir de
rentrer avec une nature au gasoil dans
Paris est-ce que ça va empêcher le
réchauffement de la planète non ce sera
rien c'est un égoïsme
bobo parisien bon on voit que c'est pas
gagné en France Mathilde la voiture
reste un objet éminemment politique et
explosif y a-t-il Mathieu un sujet plus
puissant que la voiture dans
l'inconscient collectif français depuis
la Citroën DS de Roland Bart dans ses
célèbres mythologies l'automobile que ce
soit les fleurons industriels tricolores
mais aussi l'équipement massif des
ménages n'a cessé d'irriguer notre
imaginaire la voiture objet
identitaire donc est forcément de plus
en plus clivant on en a parlé
inflammable pour tout président parce
qu'il touche bien sûr au quotidien à la
liberté aujourd'hui 85% des foyers
français possèdent au moins une selon
l'Ifop avec évidemment des grandes
disparités puisque à Paris la proportion
s'établit à seulement 35%. pour
schématiser la France Perry urbaine qui
doit prendre sa voiture pour aller
travailler s'opposerait à celle des
métropoles les classes plutôt aisées et
adeptes de la trottinette ou des
mobilités qu'on appelle douce les aides
et feux confirment ce phénomène de
polarisation les enquêtes d'opinion
montrent une opinion coupée en deux par
rapport à ce à ce dispositif et plus
révélateur selon une étude opinionweb
42% des automobilistes issus des classes
modestes se disent déterminer à conduire
leur véhicule à continuer à l'utiliser
malgré l'interdiction annoncée
exactement et 75% des ménages modestes
interrogés affirme aussi que la voiture
bien sûr reste indispensable pour eux
pour se rendre au travail 60% des plans
ne pas avoir d'offres de transport
adapté c'est ce qui fait dire à Marine
Tondelier la patronne des Verts que nous
avons un problème avec la voiture on
l'écoute on imprime de rapport à la
bagnole dans ce pays qui est en partie
subie parce que les transports en commun
ça va pas et que quand on parle d'un
ticket climat qui peut engranger ça va
pas et que vous parlerez de fiabilité
des trains d'investissement ferroviaire
et alors justement comment les
politiques se saisissent-ils d'un sujet
aussi sensible que voulez-vous les
Français aiment la bagnole c'est ce que
disait à l'époque Georges Pompidou
l'ancien président considérait même que
c'était à la ville de s'adapter à la
voiture et non l'inverse la tendance
évidemment à bien changer on parle des
ZFE on a évoqué les 80 km/h on peut
citer l'interdiction de la voiture
thermique d'ici à 2035 une autre bombe à
retardement politique depuis les gilets
jaunes et la révolte contre la taxe
carbone on sent dont en plus une une
prudence des politiques sur ce sujet on
a entendu Olivier Marleix c'est à dire
que au delà du camp écologiste il est
très compliqué pour les responsable
politique d'assumer vraiment un discours
anti voiture fort
risque de passer pour un affreux bobo
techno déconnecté comme le dit Olivier
Marley
Marleix alors qu'il l'a dit clairement
et c'est un problème de santé publique
je suis souvent d'accord avec Olivier
marlex pas tout à fait sur ce sujet mais
c'est en train de dépasser les clivages
politiques ne croyez pas j'ai eu des
présidents de métropole de tendance
verte comme Madame Tondelier qui nous
disait il faut arrêter avec cette
écologie punitive donc eux-mêmes sont
conscients quand ils sont confrontés
directement à la réalité de leurs
administrer aux difficultés de mise en
place qu'il faut revoir les schémas de
restriction et donner un petit peu de
d'oxygène il y a des députés de la
France insoumise qui notamment à
Marseille demande l'arrêt total des
adefe donc ça dépasse les clivages
politiques de dire les gens de droite
aiment les voitures
ils se décrivait en bouseux et qui
montait la capitale
je parle d'Olivier par Alex justement
Philippe pour poursuivre avec vous les
et des feux mais aussi le 0 article
artificialisation nette ça c'est pour
les sols et puis tout tous les autres ça
commence à faire beaucoup de contraintes
pour les communes non est-ce qu'il faut
faire une pause comme le disait un
certain Emmanuel Macron il a passé
longtemps extraordinaire notre président
de la République qui dit qu'il faut
qu'il faut qu'on fasse une pause et d'un
autre côté il y a des annonces tout à
fait différentes de sa première ministre
qui va qui vont totalement à l'encontre
de ce qu'il a pu dire il y a quelques
jours bien sûr que c'est beaucoup de
contraintes aujourd'hui pour les élus
locaux j'ai mon collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc qui se bat pour essayer de rendre
le zan beaucoup plus acceptable pour
qu'on garde cette cette ambition
écologique est indispensable mais d'un
autre côté il y a une réalité sur le
terrain sur les situations qui fait que
ces mesures sont totalement déconnectées
que ce soit le Zen quand il est appliqué
de telle manière que ce soit les zones
affaiblissement quand elles sont
appliquées telles qu'elles sont prévues
aujourd'hui et pour les particuliers
Erwan ça fait aussi beaucoup de choses
d'acceptation d'AC rentabilité tout à
l'heure le problème c'est qu'on part pas
de zéro en fait on part avec un gros
gros handicap le dernier des des
handicaps c'est les années 2000 je crois
que c'était 2007 de Grenelle de
l'environnement quand on to diesel et
que on est arrivé à aujourd'hui est une
aberration absolue technique
écologique etc c'était des toutes
petites voitures diesel quand on quand
on savait que il y avait 20% de de
surcoût bref on poussait au tout diesel
parce que à l'époque on se disait que ça
émettait moins de CO2 puis après là on
est revenu on est revenu à l'envers
après on a découvert que l'industrie
automobile avait égorgé quand même aussi
sur les années 80 je crois qu'il y a eu
un rapport en 1986 et puis ça a voulu le
l'enterrer en tout cas elle est
l'industrie automobile a voulu enterrer
on savait déjà que que c'était ça posait
un problème à la fois écologique et un
problème de santé et et on l'a enterré
en fait tout ce qu'on enterre à un
moment nous revient dans la figure et
donc je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui
est dit ici sur sur les mesures sur sur
l'acceptabilité sur les problèmes
moi-même je parlais tout à l'heure de
casse sociale mais ce qui se passe il
n'y a pas une vérité dans cette histoire
il y a deux vérités que ça il y a pas
une vérité un mensonge il y a deux
vérités qui s'affrontent une première
c'est la vérité sur ce que vivent les
Français je donne juste un petit exemple
d'un témoignage que j'ai eu à pas très
longtemps de aller un bobo parisien qui
avait acheté il y a quelques années une
maison à la campagne il me raconte que
bah il achète une petite voiture petite
voiture de 3 m 3000 euros voilà et puis
demande à son à son assurance d'avoir
faible kilométrage parce que bah il y va
en train sa voiture l'attend à la gare
puis ensuite il va acheter le pain il
fait quelques brocantes bref le bobo
parisien parfait au bout de six mois il
rappelle son assurance et lui dit ok
mais c'est tombé le petit kilométrage
mettez-moi un kilométrage plein pot
parce que même quand je viens que le
week-end j'ai tellement besoin de la
voiture simplement comme tout comme tous
mes voisins que je fais 10 15000 km
allez 12000 km par an et tout ça pour
dire que il s'est rendu compte il a vécu
de ce que c'était d'avoir de cette
dépendance à la voiture donc encore une
fois il y a pas une il y en a deux la
première c'est le le
millefeuille de contraintes qu'on est en
train de construire et qui est
effectivement de plus en plus dur c'est
d'être qu'on a qu'on nous a légué parce
qu'on parle souvent de dette aux
générations de futures mais les
générations d'aujourd'hui sur supportent
déjà une dette d'une part et d'autre
part la dette climatique qui va nous
coûter plus on attend de plus en plus
cher parce que Martin qu'on a pas le
choix c'est vrai que ça fait plus de
contraintes pour les élus plus de
contraintes pour les particuliers plus
de contraintes pour tout le monde mais
on n'a pas le choix l'urgence
parle aussi ça elle attend pas et en
fait on sait bien que ces enjeux
écologiques et sanitaires
va générer plus de pauvreté plus
d'inégalités on le voit déjà que ce soit
l'international où on voit toutes ces
populations qui subissent des
inondations et qui aujourd'hui étaient
qui sont qui tombent dans l'extrême
pauvreté en France on le voit aussi on a
un département urgence France ou quand
on a des canicules quand on a des
inondations quand on a des feux les
familles qui étaient sur le fil tombent
dans la précarité parce que du jour au
lendemain elle se retrouve sans maison
parce que elles ont subi une grande
inondation donc oui bien sûr il y a des
contraintes mais en fait on a un enjeu à
agir alors il faut agir avec
discernement c'est sûr qu'il faut faire
preuve de pragmatisme aujourd'hui
mais on a pour ces collectivités on
évoquait Valenciennes par exemple elle
sont son son contrainte c'est 2025 avoir
mis en route le processus de la zone
affaiblissement mais attention en 2025
ça ne veut pas dire que les véhicules
critères 4 et 5 ne pourront plus
circuler on doit faire un calendrier qui
est adapté pour autant il faut être
vigilant à se dire bon certes on a du
temps il faut l'adapter le calendrier
mais il faut proposer des choses et des
vrais des vrais projets
systémiques et pour continuer parce
qu'on a beaucoup parlé de la du véhicule
électrique aujourd'hui il est pas
accessible pour les plus précaires
aujourd'hui même si on a des aides qui
peuvent être de plus en plus ciblées
sauf le bonus écologique qui pose un
problème mais la prime à la conversion
les aide locale sont ciblées aujourd'hui
il y a un délai de 2 à 6 mois pour
obtenir les aides donc quand on est au
RSA quand on est intérimaire on n'a pas
17000 euros 10000 euros même si ces
aides étaient sur ces montants là à
avancer trois mois parce qu'en fait on a
3000 euros 5000 euros à mettre dans un
micro crédit donc tant qu'on aura
des microcrédits attention le véhicule
électrique c'est un horizon pour les
personnes en précarité dans 20 ans il
faut
entre temps on a quand même la
possibilité d'aller sur des véhicules
critères 1 nous on voit les personnes
qu'on accompagne sur microcrédits etc
c'est de passer déjà d'un véhicule
diesel ancien à au moins un véhicule
critère 1 ou là on peut avoir des
véhicules qui sont financièrement plus
accessibles donc il y a des rythmes
différents selon les situations et les
territoires différents c'est la fin de
ce débat merci à tous d'y avoir
participé c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous de l'avoir regardé vous
retrouverez Thomas Hugues lundi dans ce
fauteuil pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public et demain c'est Sylvie Berman
ancien ambassadrice de France en Chine
au Royaume-Uni en Russie qui sera à 8h
l'invité de la matinale de Public Sénat
au revoir